[Music]
the quest for the perfect tree is a
right of the holiday season and ever
since the late 19th century people have
been trying to come up with an
artificial version first there were
feather trees and later trees made of
animal bristles but by the 1960s the use
of synthetics finally gave us the
perfect fake fur today's faux furs can
be several stories tall big enough for
your town square you can get them with
many of the trimmings
so decorating isn't such a stretch these
big artificial trees start with a steel
skeleton rollers bend steel tubing into
arcs they'll be joined to form the base
of the framework workers weld vertical
supports to the arcs building the
structure in sections
a spray of polyester powder gives the
welded metal a smooth finish that's
actually tougher than paint they bake
the parts to set the coating
[Music]
after a quick cooling it's time to
assemble all the pieces
[Music]
they fasten the structure together with
u-bolts and a ratchet
[Music]
meanwhile a roll of green PVC plastic
winds its way towards a roller equipped
with many circular cutters they slice it
into four inch wide strips each of the
narrow plastic strips then goes under a
roller with even more blades they shred
it into a needle-like configuration
leaving a solid spine at the center to
hold the simulated needles together an
automated spool then winds up the
fringed green PVC
these artificial needles come in an
assortment of colors so if you want
blitz you can really go out on a limb
here streams of the fringed green and a
strip of brown PVC travel over tension
control guides steel wire unwinds and
merges with the green and brown PVC this
machine twist them together the brown
strip lands at the core of the twisted
fringe creating the illusion of a stem
among the needles this twisting
technology turns out a continuous supply
of artificial greenery giant scissors
slice it to the correct length
[Music]
to make branches that appear snow tipped
this machine twists and then frost the
PVC needles with a spray of white latex
paint they use this ring fastener to
crimp the artificial foliage together
branch by branch this creates a tightly
knit massive greenery that will be used
to cover the trees framework
[Music]
they apply single Garland's on key parts
of the tree grid first using a handheld
pneumatic fastener they fill in the
sections between them with the assemble
branches this is easier than attaching
them to the framework branch by branch
[Music]
they string the lights and then plug
them in to check each ball after all
it's easier to change one now then after
the tree has been erected especially
since this one will be a story and a
half tall
they also wire the ornaments to the
branches it's one less job for the
customer to do and now it's time to put
up the tree
they bolt the cone of wired greenery to
the lower framework and then hook the
panels of artificial greenery onto the
rest of the structure
[Music]
it has taken just one day for this
artificial tree to come together we're
growing a real one this size would take
many years and the convenience is unreal
[Music]
you